Thank you so much for coming on the show today.
Oh, it's my pleasure.
My pleasure, so nice to see you.
I have this strange feeling
as if you've never not been on the scene.
You've been a part of these big, sweeping movies.
I mean, "The Butler" is such a big deal.
It broke all those records.
It's such an important, true story.
You worked with Oprah Winfrey,
and she's an executive producer
on your new film, "The Water Man".
What is it like working with such a legend?
You know, my relationship with her began
with us playing mother and son,
and that relationship sort of bled
beyond being in front of the camera.
She just continued to be a sort of mother figure in my life,
a great, you know, source of advice for me,
advocacy for me, encouragement for me.
We share a sensibility and, yeah, she's just been
one of my my life's greatest blessings, you know,
from being together in "The Butler".
She was one of the main reasons "Selma" even happened.
It was when I asked her to come onboard as a producer
that that really sort of gained traction.
And then, in terms of "The Water Man",
it was something I went to her
and told her I was passionate about,
and she said, "Look, I'm gonna do everything I can
to help you realize this dream."
I do feel like, when she ordains things in any way
as something we're all supposed to pay attention to, we do.
We want people to shine light on stories, history,
you know, whether it's fiction or non-fiction stories.
I mean, she started with the book club.
Stories are so important, and you know,
I heard that "E.T." was a film you saw very young.
What, may I ask, did that film do for you?
Well, I have to admit, this is incredibly surreal
for me to be talking to you about this,
because that film was so formative in my life.
It's super weird to be talking to you about it
and that Oprah is my friend.
I mean, how weird is life?
But anyway, it was formative for me.
You know, I often say it's the first time
I actually saw on film a family going through
that very tough thing of the father has left,
the kids are having to deal with where's daddy gone,
the mother is having to deal with that as well,
and then, whoosh, the adventure and the fantasy begins.
And Spielberg more than anyone, you know,
has just done that so brilliantly.
I managed to get my film to him
and he watched "The Water Man" and wrote back to me
and said, "You're a fine director
and a really good storyteller."
And I was just like, oh, my goodness.
Life is so weird.
But, anyway.
(audience applauds)
That makes me so happy.
He'll be honest, too, I do believe.
Like, he is that kind of person.
Yeah, you know, I have four kids now,
and to get to share these kinds of stories with them
is so precious to me,
because I had to go back to those films
in order to share a narrative like this to them.
So, when "The Water Man" came along,
I thought, gosh, this could be something like that
for a modern audience.
We actually have a clip from "The Water Man",
and I was wondering if you could kick it old school for us
and help us set it up.
Okay.
Is it a clip between me and Lonnie?
Guess what?
I'm about to surprise you with it.
Hold on, watch this.
Okay, okay.
If you had to choose between a short life
with a lot of love in it
and a very long life with no one left to love,
which one would you choose?
I would take a short life with your mom in it
than a long one without her.
Me, too.
(audience applauds)
I'm just so excited for this movie.
Okay, can I ask you another question?
I was reading in your life story
that you had had a point where you thought
maybe you would follow in your father's footsteps in life,
and he had gotten married when he was 40 years old,
but you met the love of your life when you were,
what was the exact age?
We were 17 and 18 when we first met.
Okay, and I was wondering,
what would you say to someone who
their life surprised them
much earlier than they had planned?
Oh, it's a beautiful question, actually,
because, as you say, my dad was my hero,
and so, basically, I was going to follow in his footsteps,
and then life happened.
I met this woman and, you know,
we became friends initially,
and then I just got to the point
where I couldn't imagine the rest of my life
without her in it, and I thought, oh, no.
It's gone and happened way earlier than I thought it would.
Is it true that the morning after your wedding,
there was a towel. (laughs)
Okay, so I am,
I am anally tidy.
My wife's name is Jessica,
and she grew up being called messy Jessie.
So, you know, we had a beautiful wedding.
We had our wedding night, and it's the next morning,
and my new wife, my brand new wife goes in the shower.
She's had a shower.
She comes in and she takes off her towel
and she throws it on the floor and presents herself
in all of her nakedness,
and the first thing I did was go (yells)
I was looking at the towel,
and she thought, oh, dear, we may have a problem here.
I love your love story with your wife so much
and I just wanted to celebrate it.
(upbeat music)